since President Trump took office
there's been a lot of negative news
about our relationship with Mexico and
Mexican immigration well I want to take
things in a more positive direction so
here's the plan as I've said I'm flying
to Mexico City where I'm gonna rent a
television studio and shoot an episode
of our show with the help of an all
Mexican staff crew guests and studio
audience we're calling it Cohn Without
Borders
made in Mexico here's a great part we
already have two great guests one of the
stars of rogue one a Star Wars story
diego luna is going to be on the show
and the former President of Mexico
Vicente Fox is on the show you may you
may know Vicente Fox by his many tweets
including this one Donald do I need to
say it one more time
Mexico won't give a single peso for that
hashtag
mwah
which leads me to my next point after I
interviewed Vicente Fox there's a good
chance I will not be allowed back into
the United States you laugh as I'd say
it's 50/50 now if I'm barred from
returning to the United States I do have
a plan okay here's the plan if I don't
come back it's all been thought out Andy
Richter will take over this show as host
I think he's going to do an amazing job
our a trombone player la Bamba will take
over all of Andy's duties la Bamba will
be replaced by this 23 pound salmon and
finally all of my parental and husbandly
duties will be taken over by my good
friend actor Timothy Olyphant
that was my wife's idea
anyway it's gonna be a great show corner
without borders made in Mexico will air
on Wednesday March 1st at 10 o'clock
p.m. right here on TBS so check it out
[Applause]
you